[Music]
[Applause]
living with the lemon drop up at last
and drew the foul watch other odd lens
ition at times and if you watch him he
picks up a lot of ticky tack Fowler in
Townsville two dirt roads what eight
exploding to the rim had to guard zach
lavine last year's dirt gross he pits
his hurt the way Milwaukee is playing
right now you know losing bras and hurt
them but at the same time they have done
a good job of surrounding you know Yanis
with shooters as time these two teams
met Toronto so I want to get them out
running
[Applause]
jump shot no good Zack came in averaging
24 points per game rose off the dribble
and off the glass what a nice touch and
finish from Derrick Rose it's a nice
return from the hometown kid here to
Chicago
don't beat three of up in this game
feeds into pass pass nice cut bike a
burro horses pass eyes up the floor and
a nice bounce pass to TLC in the game
44% 1530
[Music]
boiler the owing kick why lemon almost
fouled two guys on the play watching you
and that set as you would expect of
stretches of sloppy play highlight play
as well
Walt lemon jr. drives and Knicks just
not ready coming out of that timeout
Steve loose admits that quickness Dodson
look like easily cope I don't know I
guess that's California
you know I know those guys that they
were 10 years old Chris Lopez their
older brother Chris Dunn just draped
over Derek
thing of beauty for the floor and he's
taking us on as a challenge and it goes
right actor Lemmon screened by Feliciano
spins in the paint shot up and good what
a shot by Walter lemon ranked says our
Honda Drive of the game Walter lemon it
was no doubt he was going for it and
I've always said